to put it in context I'm joined by Mike
Sweeney and a five-time MLB All-Star
Mike you've been talking to a lot of
players about the Dodgers decision to
honor this group what are they telling
you about the conflict they're feeling
between their franchise and their faith
well you saw the last week you know a
wonderful Christian men like Clayton
Kershaw Blake trynan of the Dodgers
speaking out against the organization
that employs him saying look we're not
even Catholics yet this anti-catholic
hate group we we don't support the
Dodgers crowning these men that dress up
in the sacred beauty of a habit of a nun
and Crown them as Community Heroes
Trevor Williams pitcher for the
Washington Nationals a brother in Christ
that I'm in a Bible study with down in
San Diego he he spoke out and I think
baseball players they just want to be
baseball players I remember as a young
boy not a better feeling in the world
when my dad would come home from work
and he'd have tickets to go watch the
Angels game or the Dodgers game and my
brother and I would sit with our hero
and be inspired by some of the heroes of
our our youth these baseball players and
the baseball players don't want to be
political pawns and you know quite
frankly the way the Dodgers are handling
things I won't be taking my three boys
who love baseball up to child that
Chavez Ravine anytime soon it's really
it's sad it's really sad and I mean you
know if it weren't for the Catholic
League who objected and sort of
mobilized their people the day after the
Dodgers walked it back and then they
they decide to walk back the walk back
and and honor this group but if they
wanted to honor a group of nuns or a
group of women who cared for for gay
people they should have looked no
further than the missionaries of Charity
Mother Teresa's nuns here in New York
they did that for years when no one
cared Mike Major League Baseball changed
their Twitter logo to celebrate pride
month but after Twitter users lashed out
the logo went from this yesterday to
this today
your thought your reaction to this the
MLB is denying that the outrage had
anything to do with it by the way they
told Newsweek the organization always
planned to recognize the beginning of
pride month uh and then Friday Mark Lou
Gehrig's day which is celebrated League
wide and so they updated the profile to
reflect that
yeah Clayton Kershaw spoke out about the
Dodgers now having Christian family day
back at Dodger Stadium and I was a
member of teams that we spoke after the
games fans would stick around but even
as a Christian as a Catholic that loves
our Lord we would never require some of
our our brothers on the team that were
Islamic or Jewish or non of of any faith
at all to go on Christian family day and
be forced to wear a crucifix or a cross
on their Jersey no we love we love our
brothers on our team and we're baseball
players we're not political figures but
yeah to to the LA Dodgers like you know
why are you celebrating a group that is
hateful you're talking about inclusion
diversity well celebrate these beautiful
nuns that walk the streets of LA every
day and feed the Homeless and care for
those that are in AIDS victims and those
dying in hospitals those are the true
heroes of the community and also just
you're alienating two-thirds of Los
Angeles population
identify themselves as Christians half
of that group are Catholic six and now
you're just spitting on your fans saying
we don't care what you think we don't
care what you believe because we're
going to celebrate something we're going
to push a political agenda so it breaks
my heart as a as a former Major League
player but Raymond I just got out of
maths about
40 minutes ago and the Gospel reading
tonight was Matthew chapter 22 and Jesus
says the two greatest Commandments love
the Lord God with all your heart with
all your mind with all your soul and
love your neighbor as yourself to these
men that dress up in the beautiful
habits of these holy women that give
their life to Jesus and His Holy
Catholic church and mock everything that
is sacred and beautiful
I want you to know sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence that Christ loves you he died
for you and please quit mocking quit
mocking and destroying and blaspheming
His holy church you are loved by God and
called to be a saint so I I was praying
I was fasting all day for these men and
I was I was praying that they would too
have a conversion Mike
there but you know what what a beautiful
way to end this have a great weekend and
I thank you for being here hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else